going after Heisenberg's daughter that's
a different kind of balls right there
you go Franco why him so why him is a
comedy starring James Franco and Bryan
Cranston so Bryan Cranston's daughter
has started dating this guy so she's
going to introduce this guy to the
family for Christmas and hopefully it
all works out that guy is James Franco
he's an internet billionaire who's made
his money making app games on phones so
James Franco's character wants to marry
this girl Bryan Cranston's like no I
haven't the one who knocks you're not
marrying her thus here's the comedy and
his comedy that number one goal for a
comedy is to make me laugh make you
laugh make us laugh and I laughed as
some in here that worked for me man I
mean you look at Bryan Cranston before
he was Heisenberg before everyone knew
him in Breaking Bad this dude was a
comedic actor but he's good the dude's
just a talented actor for drama and
comedy but James Franco I'm telling you
when this guy brings it for comedy he
brings it James Franco's that actor that
when he applies himself he's really good
and then when he's not when he's in a
dip people give him I give him
and then he'll do something to impress
everybody again it's like oh yeah he's
talented and then years will go by where
he's not it's just like he'll get
again it's just - his life is a roller
coaster man there's something about him
and the accurate portrayal and
representation of someone who works on
line a secret's out when people find
success on line they just work by
themselves on line they're not used to
answering to other people so there's no
real box and dynamic of rules socially
speaking anyway so they start becoming
awkward and they have no filter I've
never had a filter I've always been
filterless
so it was never really a shock or a
change or the people around me to deal
with that but I've known and seen other
people where it's like you're just
progressively getting weird you go you
but this movie hits you with some
laughter win keegan-michael key plays
James Franco's bodyguard in this movie
how good is that dude like is he gonna
run the world one day big surprising I
hope I'm pronouncing her name right
Megan Mullally Mullaly the mom in this
movie dude she was hysterical when this
lady is straight-up having some of the
funniest lines and funniest delivery in
here I was shocked I was like being more
stuff place her dry sense of humor works
so well when you had this other spectrum
of someone who's such
eccentric personality doesn't mean the
movie doesn't have flaws it certainly
has flaws I mean first and foremost
let's address the fact that it's just
it's that movie the movie about the
son-in-law who wants to impress the
would-be dad omit its son-in-law
son-in-law 2016 and that there's no real
surprises in this movie whatsoever me
you're just kind of watching it unfold
hoping it makes you laugh through this
predictable plot and it does the premise
is a bit OneNote it goes on for a bit
longer than it's like 15 minutes could
have been shaved off this movie yes some
dumb humor in it too a couple of moments
of lowbrow humor but in a world where
you'll have a scene with that but you
have a few people bouncing off of each
other with it not all of them are going
to have lowbrow humor you have a few
different personalities you can really
hit the pocket of most people who go to
this movie and I for one enjoyed it guys
in the end why him had enough in there
to work I thought I was gonna walk out
of this movie all over it I
didn't I will say why him was definitely
a good time no alcohol required right
guys so why him have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]